[Music]
in horrible parenting news for NGO yeah
never will never be horrible cut it up
the best way to be a good parent is to
be absent whoa
that's exactly right that's true no way
you got to be huggers in that way you
can never [ __ ] up who's right in there
yeah BAM you something that you didn't
do exactly that's right for never being
there damn deep wounds submitted by
bigger than bark okay bear then barter
bigger than bark they're gonna [ __ ]
bar bigger than Barton what do you think
of that 13 siblings ages 2 to 29 were
found shackled in their home in Paris
California by their parents damn I heard
13 siblings I just have a healthy sex
life all right my 20 years one of them
escapes save the other ones that's a lot
of killer here I want I don't know any
of this stuff double decade sex licenses
that means she's very fertile triple
he's almost 30 and they starved them and
chef-y a wallet to me one of them
escaped and notified the authorities to
save the other ones oh wait I guess I
want to go backwards
we're like what were the conditions so
that I know why this game well okay I
don't know why they escaped but though
they were shallow the bed they were
starving they weren't being fed they
were being tortured and tortured what
were the parents doing
I think it was like like a sex ring
thing can you tell me in order to if I'm
so confused pretty confused I don't know
anything about this story I briefly saw
it uh where was it I was leaving to film
today and the mom was watching the news
and then I just saw something and I'm
like god I can't stay but said I don't
know anything okay
so the parents names is David and Louise
[ __ ]
turbine David is 57 Louise is 49
apparently they got married
sixteen and she's just completely cut
herself off from her family and they
just started popping out kids
immediately it seems like they were
horny so they live in a four-bedroom
house and when they were found they were
some of them were shackled to their beds
or furniture and some of the rooms were
soaked in urine and it was just so dirty
like there's no way like any kids should
be living in that environment at all
they were so malnourished that the 29
year old was only 82 pounds oh my god
yeah
and so they were only being fed one meal
a day and we're only allowed to shower
twice a year what the [ __ ] why cuz the
water behind you rolled how'd it go to
this for ya that's [ __ ] horrible yeah
that person has no chance of a regular
life after no for sure
hey we're not allowed to watch TV and
apparently now it's coming out no TV
he's gonna say that's like the last no
but they did have Netflix yeah that's
not bad it's like they do have Hulu it's
like oh that's bad it's not too bad no
so then really babe um yeah so now it's
coming out that the parents would buy
pies and toys and pretty much just
taught the kids with it cuz they would
eat the pies themselves they would never
open the toys [ __ ] Legos and they're
all putting it together no you can't and
like that's cuz it sounds like a [ __ ]
Disney movie but it's kind of funny well
not like I mean it sounds like we some
Cinderella [ __ ] this is some [ __ ]
sick [ __ ] I want to murder these people
yeah they've been arrested but to even
think of I'm gonna go to the toy store
as a grown 50 year old to so I could so
I could play with [ __ ] GI Joe in
front of my children that's [ __ ]
hilarious well they're mentioning that
the toys will never be
it was just there it's like taunt the
kids like they can't even play with it
that's [ __ ] no that's [ __ ] up this
dude looks hella weird by the way I saw
yeah you've got like girl like a like a
bowl cut like I won't see the culprits
oh wait wait keep going cuz you're I I'm
still so interested because I don't know
anything looks like a Raggedy Ann doll
yeah so the 17 year old is as Niki
mentioned earlier their 17-year old was
able to escape the house early in the
morning she had a cell phone with her
she was able to call 9-1-1 and then the
police once they they got ahold of her
like once they saw her got she was 10
they couldn't yeah exactly cuz she was
so malnourished Wow so toast they're not
able to even grow properly they're soul
melon like North Korean oh this dude man
look at this cat when was this picture
taken since before they like this is
they were like considered normal still
like they have a lot of pictures oh
they're not doing anything to the baby
so this is before why they look so happy
they probably don't know what happy is
done and they don't look at these
they're outside they're not change I
mean do they look under what it would go
to Disneyland often so at least had the
one that looks like a baby that's the 29
year olds wait they'll go to Disneyland
yeah cuz the parents are obsessive
Disneyland so what's there they would go
dude you know who this can't looks like
he looks like and this guy should also
be arrested the owner of the Oakland
Raiders Mark Davis again
he's like a bowl haircut same [ __ ] same
time all the kids so we have I think
three boys so they unshackle him go to
Disney and then come back to shackle
them again their dad looks like a
medieval peasant yeah he was a jester do
I want that man not anymore after
[ __ ] Aerostar I'm not too sure buddy
couldn't bring a lot of friends so how
did the seventeen-year-old escape that's
the thing I don't know they just say
like you somehow managed to I mean this
is crazy
I can't Mickey the only one not fogged
on her you already saw their faces and
the other pictures though yeah this is
wrong
so they would buy all these Disney
clothes matching clothes clothes and
they said the reason why they would
match the clothes all the girls had the
exact same haircut and same with the
boys they all have bull cuts like their
dad and gather saying I was like for
safety purposes so they won't lose their
kids is the mom didn't ever get sexually
that we used oh my god oh I was reading
some weird [ __ ] this fool looks like he
[ __ ] farms turnips he looks like he's
never going to Disney alisios hair aha
Steve the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] daddy issues
pay the piper
I want to chain them to the bed and play
with toys in front of them and I'm gonna
make them watch me going to Disneyland
and over and over no we taking a Disney
man and we don't let him going any right
seven seven of these kids are adults the
eight they're over the age of eighteen
but they all look like kids they all
look like they're not adults man they'll
never be a dull you think they're doing
this on purpose to keep them cute and
young like Disney like because there's a
good things and make them live in here
yeah because they're because they're
annoying so like they dig and then so
neighbors were saying that the kids only
came out at night so they were super
pale and like one neighbor was like
energy start playing in the backyard at
night that they would just come out in
it other neighbors said that they would
see the kids digging in the trash for
food Oh mine yeah and then we said [ __ ]
I love this digging for food yeah what
the [ __ ] don't say [ __ ] and they'd look
malnourished it'll look they look like
that family like it's not understand
that they're minded like this one
neighbor it was like yeah they reminded
me of the Twilight family is just so
pale I'm like I would call the cops just
because they look weird but it
so weird ass [ __ ] family across the
street and who the hell has 13 kids
nowadays one or two is fine three and
over it's weird I'm assuming they're
homeschooled yeah so the hell the home
was registered as a private school and
the dad was registered as a prince and
they don't check that [ __ ] no because
it's a private school the Department of
Education doesn't need to check the
police change that see the principal the
teacher and the [ __ ] school security
the treasurer 88 yeah yeah and the mom
was a lunch lady yeah previously they
had filed for bankruptcy bankruptcy they
lived in Texas and then they moved to
California recently Oh what that's a
stupid move well because you know you
get more money though if you're on their
welfare system we'll be rolling over
well they said they filed for bankruptcy
I don't know I think you get more money
for dependents or something right if you
have that many kids yeah was an engineer
he would get 140k a year and louise is
just well they do have like 2030 [ __ ]
money oh did Neil and yeah it's just
Disneyland just to enter
yeah you take 13 kids you do take 13
kids to the pizza rocket you're gonna be
bleeding up to ask for money after that
yeah and then so Louise's sister has
been interviewed now and like she's come
forward saying that David would watch
her shower oh they were [ __ ] said [ __ ]
yeah yeah so like Elizabeth lived with
them for a few months and she was
younger in Texas and that she was
treated like one of the kids that she
also had rules and that she felt
uncomfortable around David but he never
actually did anything they should beat
up everyone what the weird haircut wait
but they would he would watch her shower
she's saying that like he would come
like she would be showering and he'd
come into the shower as a joke and watch
her shower but she was younger too like
what's the setup I have no idea because
I don't see how this could be a
punchline for any joke if it's yours
it's the way you just did it was kind of
fun
when you pop in like that done I need to
know the Senate surprise surprise
[ __ ] hate this is someone how did
people get away with this for so long I
got to chain him up for 30 years so
where are they living now they're living
in like shelters or something or like
foster homes the last thing I heard was
that they were in the hospital trying to
like make sure that they're okay and
that they're slowly that now they get to
watch TV and that they're slowly thank
God
that's important I will give the food so
a kid so much food yeah you have to
slowly do it or they die yeah cuz
there's their body doesn't know how to
digest watch these guys get to watch
Breaking Bad for like the first time so
lucky
I'm jealous that's pretty cool so you
can't just hit him to Hometown Buffet
you can watch Dexter before they found
out that Dexter sucks after they can
watch they probably don't even see Star
Wars they could watch Star Wars for the
first time daddy huh Oh boomer because
the first ones kind of like old school
no but it's like the technology never
the beauty [ __ ] oh that's got to start
first and before they can watch TV then
right so they go to Disneyland but they
don't get any of the references because
they haven't been able to watch the
movies they don't know anything maybe
they watch Disney movies maybe that
maybe not like they were sexually abused
for sure man that makes it what do they
get to eat like oatmeal and bananas or
something because if once they could
start eating things I'll take them to
all the all-you-can-eat places Korean
barbecue Hometown Buffet Shakey's Pizza
how do I get a table for like 30 kids
dude imagine watching imagine watching
one of these kids playing on 3d like I'm
like a little my caviar thing like
watching them do that [ __ ] did you'd be
like what the [ __ ] I mean who knows how
sheltered they were if they were going
to Disneyland they went to Vegas further
they're also paint on themselves - yeah
I think parents were playing with toys
in front of them they probably had a TV
and being like you can't watch this they
turn it the other way or maybe only
plays Disney movies that's [ __ ] dog
whatever the parents
dead now no so they've been arrested on
nine counts of torture and ten counts of
child endangerment their bail is set at
nine million each but yeah but I mean
why can't we tortured and why do they
just sit in prison and get fed yeah like
it's not fair that they treat someone
like inhumane yeah and then they get
treated humane like that doesn't make
any sense to me I agree I don't Amalia
if they treat someone in humanely then
they should be you know why it's because
of it's because of false accusations
like of people getting convicted that
they were innocent so it's like they're
already guilty because they look weird I
know well they're guilty for sure for
sure just look at the haircutter kids
who testify against them yeah 13
children like weird like in his hair his
hair Cologne should be a [ __ ]
misdemeanor
I should be beautiful sure for sure
prove it like that then you can are
allowed to get tortured his hair should
be a $25,000 fine because he just
polluted my eyes and saying I think the
same thing about about Mark Davis
tonight Oakland Raiders visually at
least thank you see he looks [ __ ]
weird
[Music]